Hi everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google.
My name is Dana Han Klein.
And today it is my pleasure to welcome David Guggenheim
aren't here today for,
he named me Malala.
Uh,
it was a wonderful documentary.
Can you tell us how you got involved in it?
Well,
the producers of the movie,
um,
Walter Parks and Lori Mcdonald's wanted to make a,
uh,
a movie.
They had gotten the life rights to her,
uh,
to make a movie with an actor.
And they went and met with her where she lives in Birmingham,
England.
And there were so blown away they thought who could play her because they
thought it should be a documentary.
So they brought it to me,
probably a good decision.
Um,
so they brought to you,
it was an excellent decision.
So they brought it to you and all the movie.
I did see the movie and it was an excellent,
is there,
there's no one who could play her.
She's herself,
you know,
um,
what she did,
on documentary played by Malala herself.
It's interesting.
I'd see that as a followup maybe.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Um,
so where are you on board right away?
Or were you,
did you have to be convinced or were you just like,
I,
I'm so excited.
I would love to make this documentary.
They call me and I said,
give me a few days and I just read everything I could read because the story of
a girl being shot on her school bus is this.
But I wanted more and I wanted to know if there's something I could add to it
because there was a book about her and everything.
And I immediately fixated very quickly on this father daughter relationship.
You know,
he,
her father names her after girl who speaks out in this killed for speaking out.
I felt like epic Greek
thing.
And so she's born with this name that has all this meaning to it.
And it made me want to know,
you know,
did she become this girl just because her father named her this or because of
another reason.
He sort of set her destiny possibly for her.
Um,
uh,
one of the,
um,
I,
that was one of the things I noticed that it's this kind of beautiful father
daughter story.
Um,
what,
what was it like striking the balance between telling his story because it is
such an important part of the backstory of how she came to be,
how her personality was shaped and telling her story because they are so
intertwined.
She,
I think she said at one point like they were like two extensions of the same
soul.
He says,
we're,
we're like one soul in two different bodies.
And in fact,
there was a,
one of my editors said,
we can't put that in the movie.
It's too creepy.
But I said,
no,
it's beautiful.
Like the idea,
and I have two daughters,
uh,
this idea of one soul into different buddies that's attachment that they have.
And it's really,
when you see the movie,
there's this incredible attachment.
And I had these two daughters
and they are a complete mystery to me.
Like my son makes perfect sense.
It's like,
man,
you know,
we just look.
It's like we were,
but my daughters,
I don't know how to talk to them and I want them to feel my love and I want them
to be anything they want to be.
And yet I have no clue as to how to be a father.
And so making this movie,
I found out that I learned from this Pakistani 7,000 miles away from my live,
this Muslim man how to be a father to my own children.
It's interesting you bring that up,
that you connect with your son easily and,
and,
and Malala,
his mother is this figure in this movie,
you know,
obviously she loves her mother very much,
but I was almost expecting to see more of her.
Yeah.
But it,
it kind of became clear in that she,
she has this very unique connection with her father.
Was there at any point where you're going to try and explore the mother's a
story more or,
or is it just,
was it immediate?
Everybody asks about it because of the mom is sort of hovering in the background
and she's a traditional path tune woman and sort of being on camera seen as
immodest.
Um,
and so it took me very long time to get her to want to be in the movie.
In fact,
she didn't want to be in the movie at all.
And then at the very end I showed them a cut of the movie.
Um,
and the mother whispered something to Malala and patched,
turn and Valassis my mother wants to be in the money.
So I interviewed her at the last thing I did.
And so she's in the movie.
But um,
and if you know this family is,
I know them,
you realize that the mother is,
is the source of Malala is a spiritual strength and mall has this tremendous
sense of forgiveness and right and wrong that she gets from,
from her faith.
And um,
she gets her mission from her father,
but she gets to sort of steely strength,
um,
from her mom.
And then,
uh,
just last week corporate Chi,
her mom gave my kids these beautiful pass tune close.
My kids from la are like dressing like past hands now.
It's like very smart.
It's a cultural exchange.
Yeah.
Um,
well as you said,
you know,
I,
you,
you obviously had to get to know his family to make this film.
Um,
and in a sense,
because you were making a film,
it's a little bit your story too.
Um,
what are the parts that you think you brought to it that helped enhance Malala
story?
That's really interesting.
Um,
did,
I made this movie waiting for Superman,
which is about the public school system.
And in that case I narrated that movie and I put my opinion in it.
It was like an editorial,
like Davis thinks this.
Um,
and that's very different from this movie where I really feel like my job in
this was to,
to pull their story out of them.
And I said to this one,
I met them,
I was like,
let me help you tell your own story.
So if you were listening just casually,
if you would think that Malala is narrating it,
she isn't,
but she's actually talking to me about what happened.
And in that discussion she tells her own story.
And so that was my,
I guess if I,
if you were,
say I'm in the movie is only in a,
in a choice,
the sense that,
um,
I decided not to tell this big political story.
This is like the rise of the Taliban and that part of the world,
which is a very important thing to explore.
But to me what was interesting is that the,
the,
this,
this universal question of what,
what is it about a girl growing up this role?
What is it that makes her feel confident and what would lead this ordinary girl
to make this extraordinary choices,
brave choice,
to risk her life for something she believes that actually turns her into this
incredible person.
I wanted to know,
I wanted to go really deep into those choices.
Yeah.
I thought one of the wonderful things that I got of it as an audience member was
Mala is this wonderful,
eloquent,
you know,
powerful,
inspiring figure.
But there are these wonderful little moments where she's,
she's a teenage girl,
Girl.
Um,
and you,
you realize how much kind of responsibility we've assigned to her and how much
she's taken on herself,
but then,
you know,
she's giggling about,
boy,
she likes that.
She doesn't want to admit she likes.
Yeah.
Um,
and so for you,
like is that something you discovered have getting to know them or is that
something that you had like an inkling of going into this that you wanted to
tell?
Like a regular person,
regular person's story?
Well,
now I know how ignorant I was.
Um,
but I guess it's nice to go in when you're making a documentary to start kind of
ignorant and educate yourself by making the movie and sort of as your world
opens.
But I really thought I knew a lot about Muslim culture and Muslim people and I
really didn't.
And so when I rang the doorbell,
other their house,
I said,
oh,
I had all these,
all this pre conceived notions.
And then Malala answered the door and I went inside and there are kind of loud
and chaotic and funny and they're teasing each other.
And Marla was punching her brother's and there,
you know,
she's online looking up pictures of Brad Pitt and uh,
and yet they're also very deep people with a sense of purpose.
And I was like,
oh,
their kitchen table and their family is like my kitchen table.
And um,
to see that ordinariness to see that she's on one hand a girl who can go up to
President Obama and ask them a question that no adult would be brave enough to
ask.
She asked him about,
why are you sending drones into my country?
You know,
she was 17 at the time.
I would never dare ask that question.
Um,
it's probably the most sensitive question of his entire presidency.
People will look back and say,
why did you do that?
She can do that very easily.
And then she can go home and pick up her laptop.
And,
you know,
search for pictures of Roger Federer or it's like,
it's this double,
double,
double life that she has.
Um,
and it's important to see her that way because if you see her as this sort of
larger than life icon,
you forget
that she's just an ordinary girl.
And,
and,
and that's important because I want,
I really want this more than anything.
I want young girls to love this movie,
to feel like it's,
it speaks to them and that they can have a hero that they can believe in,
not just a hero that tells him that they're fat or they're dumb or they're not
famous enough and that this girl will actually is,
is inspiring in a way that can,
can challenge girls to speak out more.
I thought,
um,
it was,
it was kind of lovely seeing that and it was also lovely hearing her unbridled
passion for education and not just in the context of speaking to it like the UN
General Assembly.
You know,
you asked her what her favorite book was and you looked like you'd asked her
like to make Sophie's choice or something like that.
She was just like,
no,
I can't,
I can't pick it.
And it's,
it's someone who likes this is a company of people who are interested in
education and further ourselves here.
I think for us it's something we very much relate to.
And obviously with waiting for Superman,
it's something that you're passionate about.
Um,
what,
what are some of the other things that you think,
um,
you know,
we can do in addition to helping Malala,
uh,
to,
to kind of push education forward?
One thing is,
is
there's a lot of lip service we give to education.
Yeah.
It's really important in our kids.
I've got three kids and it's like,
and then it's real.
There's two messages.
One is it's really important and then you're with your friends.
It's like,
it's really boring and I have to go home and have to do my homework.
It's a chore.
And when you,
when you see the story,
you see a girl who is,
um,
who loves her school,
she grows up in her school.
It's,
there are other girls in her town that don't get to go to school.
So it's like this precious,
precious thing.
And now the Taliban comes in and starts blowing up schools and starts flogging
girls for going to school.
So suddenly school is this the most precious thing in her life,
which for all of us in America anyway,
it can be something that we take for granted or it's like a means to an end.
Not to do this,
to get somewhere.
And the idea that,
that,
that these ideas that our father was teaching her were precious and um,
and that to remind ourselves of that and that,
you know,
it could easily,
it could easily be taken away from us.
And the other thing is that if you look at human beings as,
as I do,
that every human being has some untapped potential.
I mean,
here,
clearly here at Google,
um,
people have gotten to where they are because I've had this potential that's that
they've found a way to tap that probably is
so much more potential that,
that,
that everyone here can still be tapped.
But you'd look at people who don't have an education as people who have,
we have yet to tap that resource.
And if you don't,
it's a very tragic thing,
but it's also what's so hard.
It's an invisible thing.
You can see refugees without a home and that's something you can look at in
struggle with.
But an unfulfilled potential is hidden and invisible.
And this idea that Malala is showing us that is what makes this story so,
so beautiful.
Um,
and have fun today.
I'd love to talk about a storytelling kind of device you use.
I'd love the animation in this film.
It was beautiful,
you know,
it was a great way to kind of not fill in the gaps but illustrate what were
saying,
um,
in an interpretive way.
What,
how did you decide to sort of use that as a vehicle?
I try not to make documentaries that are good for you.
You know,
that,
oh,
you know,
do you want to see the Martian this weekend or do you want to see,
he named me Malala and you know,
there is some of that where you say,
you know,
we really should go see this movie.
And sometimes that's important,
but I,
I want to fight against that.
I want to tell a really good story.
I want people to be moved.
I want people to laugh.
I want people to cry.
And at the end of it,
I want it to sort of move them.
And maybe there's a message in there,
but,
but you know,
we'll get to that later.
You know,
maybe you think about it on your car ride home.
But I like my movies to be an experience and I'm so,
I'm always to finding ways in which to tell the story in a new way.
And,
and,
um,
I came to this thing where it's like they're telling me the story of these
things a long time ago and it's like,
let's build an animation company in my studio.
So I,
we,
my office is in Venice.
We built an animation studio and we,
instead of,
you know,
having serious photos of the Swat valley now,
um,
I,
we got these,
these young animators from cal arts in California,
and we drew these very beautiful
painterly,
almost storybook images of their life in Pakistan.
And it has another feeling to it.
And,
um,
so you,
you really want to feel like you're watching a movie and your x and you're sort
of,
you're diving into a world that's going to sort of put a trans on you.
Yeah.
It's um,
I mean they were beautiful and it,
it was in stark contrast to sort of the documentary footage that I'm assuming
you guys got from the news and you know,
the previous historical footage of the actual kind of conditions they were in.
Um,
one thing we're fighting against here in America and I realized it is how
ignorant I was of this very deep,
rich culture in this very deep and rich religion.
Is it the,
and this is a company that's about information,
is that the,
the information that most Americans get of this part of the world is very
narrow,
very negative.
And,
and we know that like,
you know,
you get images of Isis and horrible things and not just horrible things but
horrible things for a very long time and things that feel like they'll never get
better.
And so when you see them as a,
I always think about my own emotional state is when I see these stories,
I just want to do this.
I want to turn away.
And so I thought my job is just to introduce you to this beautiful family that
is not that they're funny,
they're irreverent,
they're,
they're hilarious.
And the world where they lived in Pakistan was actually not a dangerous place.
It was paradise.
And so part of this movie is about Paradise Lost and how the paradise all of us
live in could easily be corrupted in the same way.
There's was,
you know,
when Malala was one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
it was a beautiful peaceful place.
And then only when the Taliban came in did hurt that the snake come into the
garden and their world,
this precious world that they created was that under threat.
And that's so much more interesting than the narrative.
This sort of limited diet of information we get from this part of the world.
Yeah.
Um,
I think you said it beautifully and it's,
it's one of those things where it's just like,
what if that were to happen to one of us?
You know,
like if suddenly you couldn't go back to the place that you were born and
couldn't you be with the,
you know,
that your friends for threat of death.
I don't think that's anything we as Americans,
Westerners,
whatever,
ever think about crossing your minds.
And I don't think it's necessarily something that would have crossed her mind
until it happened to her.
Right?
So it's just this sort of horrifying thing to watch happen to someone who is so
positive and wonderful.
And who knows what would've happened if it hadn't happened.
Right?
But if you heard about Malala is a lot of us did,
a girl got shot on a school bus.
He's like,
oh,
this is just a scary,
dangerous place where this happens all the time.
And it's just like,
like the streets of Chicago,
people get killed every night.
It's like,
it's just another thing.
Um,
but no,
it,
I,
the story when you watch it has so much more dimension to it.
And it is,
um,
so much so important for us to go deeper than this sort of surface story.
And you know,
this,
the Google,
like you do the first search and the Wikipedia page and it tells you the first
two things and that's one thing.
But when you know how to go deeper and you can find the richness of a really
nuanced story,
um,
that's where
you learn about the world in a really important way.
Did you feel a sense of responsibility telling a story?
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's very much more all this story and as you've said,
a lot of us I think were from the,
I hope we're familiar at least with the basic details of it,
but this is a sort of opening up to this massive medium where people are going
to see all of this.
Like where did,
where did you feel your role responsibility wise came in?
If you ask my wife,
uh,
she would tell you that the most miserable,
most consistently miserable,
like from gutter to the spare to pit of despair.
I was in the below the pit of despair for about six months.
Making this movie because I knew that this was a special story and I felt a
tremendous sense of responsibility to get it right because she's so special.
But the movie wasn't working,
so I would have a cut of the movie and I bring friends over and we'd watch the
movie and people be scratching your heads and,
and um,
and I was like,
maybe this is a movie I can't pull off.
Maybe this will suck forever.
And I'm only over a very long time.
We edited for 18 months,
which is a really,
not with three editors did.
I finally figured out sort of how to put it together because it's a very
complicated story structure when you see it.
But yeah,
I mean I just,
because we don't get enough information from this part of the world because,
uh,
my daughters don't get enough real heroes.
Um,
because her voice is so unique and so clear,
I felt a tremendous responsibility to get it right so that to the,
a lot of people would get to know her the way I got to know her.
Curious to like,
what from your perspective wasn't working about it or do we not want to go back
to that dark place?
Everyone who watched it would say,
ah,
this is good intentions,
not good film.
You know,
and you know,
it's,
you know,
when something sucks.
So it,
it was,
it was not good for a long time and,
uh,
sort of disjointed,
confusing,
boring,
Phalon suck.
Thanks for
taking the time and not abandoning it and keeping at it.
Cause you know,
it's,
it's tough on any sort of project.
I think we all know here if we want to kind of throw it away and you know,
just be like,
oh,
it's someone else's prom now where I can't do it or,
yeah.
You know,
so it's,
I think,
yeah,
you know,
good things only come out of the fifth that kind of struggle,
the struggle as true and,
and,
you know,
when you get in a bind,
um,
creatively,
sometimes it's this third your way out of it that helps you find those,
those
interesting ideas.
Like the animation was like that.
It's like,
well,
how do we tell the story of the girl she was named after a hundred years ago?
Like,
well,
you can't,
like,
what am I going to do?
You know,
do reenactment with reenactment with guys,
with helmets,
like the spears running after each other.
I like,
that's stupid.
And,
um,
so we're not the animate it,
you know,
so why not do something completely opposite,
um,
something you would never see in a documentary and,
why not get
this great composer,
Tom Newman,
who did the music for this movie?
Um,
you know,
he didn't finding Nemo and Wally and Shawshank redemption.
Then why not get a proper film composer and make it feel like a movie?
Like you're going to on a Saturday night.
Was there kind of a magic moment for you where it came together or was it just
kind of slowly realizing like,
oh,
it doesn't suck anymore?
Um,
yeah,
there was one screening where you just like,
the lights came up and everyone would just didn't say anything and you just felt
like they had just experienced what,
what I have experienced in getting to know her.
And,
and,
uh,
I think for those of you who are watching and you watch this film there,
there is this tremendous sense of like,
wonder about her and this sense of like,
oh,
I never knew that before.
But also this sense of,
oh my gosh,
what this girl did.
This unknown girl from the middle of nowhere took this incredibly brave choice
to speak up for what she believed and she helped change the world.
And she captured everyone's imagination.
And when you,
if you could,
the idea of if you,
if you go through that and experience that,
um,
at the other end,
the audience is like,
and there's no describing that.
I can only just go
there.
Yes,
it was wonderful.
And there were definitely a few moments in our screening where the air just kind
of went out of the room in a good way.
It was just like,
yeah,
we felt it.
Yeah.
I think that's what I'm always trying for us.
Like there's,
there's documentary,
which this is a documentary,
but there's a documentary and then there's,
uh,
an experience that I'm working on the experience.
Yeah.
Know you're telling a story.
It happens to be based in reality.
It happens to be a person's story,
but it's still a story in it beginning,
middle,
end.
And you know,
it's,
it's a journey for us all to go on
and people overlook that.
Like storytelling is this,
I guess storytelling,
but it's,
it,
it's,
and my father may document her too.
I said,
you know,
movies or a story.
You get to learn how to tell a story.
It's a complete mystery.
Like what is a good story?
Like we know,
we know how to build a chair,
we know how to build a table,
we know how a car works,
but how do you,
how do you tell a story?
And so
that itself is really delicate and complicated and complex.
Um,
I'd love to know what was one of the most rewarding parts of working on the film
for you?
You know,
I've directed movies,
I've directed commercials,
I've directed a lot of television,
and all those things are fun and sometimes inspiring,
sometimes
incredible.
But the idea of making a documentary that actually has this larger thing to it,
there's no better feeling in the world,
like with inconvenient truth,
the feeling like I told the story and people are are changed after having seen
it and people are changing their lives and the conversation is moving forward.
And even waiting for superman where it's like,
you know,
people are debating this and people are disagreeing with this movie or people
are liking this movie and,
but,
but there's no better feeling in the world.
And introducing this girl and her father,
um,
to the world is,
is such a,
a wonderful experience.
There's no better feeling in that.
Um,
so what's one of the most surprising things you've learned about Malala and her
family during this experience and then what's the most surprising things you've
learned about yourself during the extreme?
A
two parter.
The surprising thing is like,
it's like a grocery list of surprising things.
I mean just how funny she is,
how kind she is.
Like,
I got an email,
an email from her today saying,
you know,
the movie's coming out today in la,
in New York.
And you know,
I've made movies with famous actors and famous politicians and,
and no one cares about me.
I'm just the director who annoys him with the camera.
Malala was a very first person of any movie I've ever made who she sent me.
And she goes,
I know this is a vulnerable stressful day for you and,
and I know that the reviews are coming out and I just want to tell you that I
love this movie and I'm proud of you.
An 18 year old girl.
I mean,
how,
how remarkable is that?
And she's got,
she's got lots of things to do,
but the fact that she's just had that,
that kind of kindness about her to reach across and think about me with is very
lovely.
So I mean,
just,
I don't think you could ask for a better endorsement than she,
she goes,
you know,
you have five stars.
Do you have my FiveStars done?
So,
but I'm your favorite yourself.
Say
My last question for you is,
what's the subject,
either documentary or fiction fictional that you haven't covered yet that you'd
like to?
Well,
I'm,
I feel like as a director,
um,
you have a cup
that as you tell your stories,
the cup empties of this fluid that is full of something and you fill that cup by
living and by reading and experiencing things.
And so,
um,
if your cup is full,
then you're ready to make a movie and when Your Cup is empty,
you should never make a movie.
And right now my Cup Cup is past empty that there's been,
you know,
the dashboard has been like,
can you filter mixed Metaphor Cup in dashboard.
But the idea is that like,
I should mind,
my plan is to be a dad,
but you know,
um,
there's so many stories out there.
There's so much to tell.
There's so many things that aggravate me and make me feel passionate.
And um,
so it could be anything.
It can be anything
forward to seeing whatever that may be.
Someday.
Hi,
I haven't seen the movie yet,
but I'm very excited to watch it.
I'm going to pick it over Martian if you gotta pick it up with the marshy.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
It looks good by the way.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
But,
uh,
still some,
I'm very interested actually that how knowing and interacted with Mandela
change.
Did you,
how
she impacted you in a way that especially you mentioned your relationship with
your daughters.
Yeah.
So I figure,
you know,
in La,
we believe in equality and girls are equal to boys.
And um,
and over there in Pakistan,
that's a patriarchal society.
And then,
mmm.
Malala's father
believed not only,
not only did he say she was equal,
he believed she was equal and he acted on it.
And sometimes when I went after I would visit them,
I would come to home to my house and I say,
you know,
you say your daughter's equal,
but like when you read the newspaper and you want to share it with somebody,
I do it with my son
and I looked past my daughter and I think,
you know,
in Pakistan there are these really strong lines of discrimination.
Girls can't go to school.
All girls can have a name or girls have to wear a certain thing.
In our world,
there are much more invisible lines there.
Cues that I think girls get,
you know,
they're,
they're told they're equal and they believe they're equal to a certain age.
And then there's this thing called the affiliate complex.
If you heard this word like at a certain age,
girls start to get,
they start to shrink.
And I,
you know,
and I worry about with that with my daughters.
And so I would go home after spending time with this family and calm and say,
I have to be,
uh,
I not only have to say my daughter's equal,
but I have to believe it and I have to act on it.
I mean,
he took a family tree that had any,
you haven't seen the movie.
So one of the scenes is,
uh,
when she was born,
there's a family tree
and it's the soft side clan,
Pashtun,
Cayenne.
And it goes back 300 years and he unrolls it and meticulously handwritten family
tree.
But,
but on the,
on the family tree,
going back 300 years,
there are no women.
They didn't think that you should record a woman.
So the woman's Dope,
the women,
your soft side women don't exist.
And the day after she was born and he takes a pen and draws a line and he rates
Malala and he says,
I'm not going to just give lip service to this.
I'm going to say that she is,
you know,
she exists.
And there's a wonderful thing when you go to another culture is at one culture,
you know,
it's like this,
um,
feedback loop.
And so I'm telling them things about my daughters and they're saying,
oh yeah,
but then suddenly they're telling me something.
And so I learned that's what I learned.
And,
and I,
and I go home tonight,
you know,
a different father because I met this father and this daughter.
Thank you.
It's,
it's interesting to hear you say that.
I,
I come from a family where there's only daughters.
So my dad didn't have a choice in,
in terms of it did.
There's just two of us.
But it's,
it's,
it's nice to see someone else leading by example and seeing somebody else who
does have a dad who's equally,
you know,
my dad's wonderful and supportive and he loves us for who we are is encouraging.
I don't ever think I felt growing up that like I was meant to be inferior.
You know,
we're in a very west Western society.
I grew up in the west and it's,
oh no,
I never felt,
yeah,
unequal.
Uh,
you know,
encouraged to pursue education.
It's,
it's wonderful.
And so it's,
it's really frustrating for me to see that there's people in the world who don't
have that same opportunity.
But when you went out of the home and into college and things like that,
did you feel cues like that or didn't matter,
uh,
meaning meaning it or even in the workplace or even in college?
Do you feel like you always feel treated equally?
Oh,
no,
no.
Which is,
which is why it's,
it's wonderful to have Malala as it,
you know,
she's this young kind of symbol of equality.
I think she even says at one point,
you know,
we're going to better the event,
but it's not about that.
It's about,
you know,
being,
being given the same opportunities and all that,
that sort of fair play.
Um,
but it's,
it's,
it's wonderful to see somebody else who had a dad who doesn't,
yeah.
Didn't treat her any differently or impact,
encouraged her to do that.
And it's nice to hear you as a father saying like,
I want to look at my daughters and,
and look at them as I wanna put my money where my mouth is and you can kind of
treat them with the same sort of thing.
I think that's what the Malala is asking of all of us.
Yeah.
If she can get you to change just in a micro way,
hopefully she made the rest of us too.
There's a story that her father told me that I'm still in in parts of Pakistan.
Women don't have names.
So you would go to a doctor's office and I would bring my daughter and it'd be
the daughter of Davis or my wife.
It'd be the wife of Davis for my mother.
My mother doesn't have a name.
It's the mother of Davis.
And so that seems like you have a name.
We have names,
we named things.
No big deal,
but heard of them having a name.
It's like the first sign of,
of percentage of,
of,
of saying you exist.
And in fact,
in Nazi Germany,
the,
the quickest way to sort of destroy people is to say you don't have a name.
We're going to put a number on you.
We're going to get to where dad to a number on you.
You are now nameless.
And so this idea of naming it says it has a real sort of strong kind of epic
thing to it.
And that's why that's in the title.
Thank you.
That's it.
That's an important thing.
Um,
well thank you so much for joining us today.
My name is Malala is in theaters.
Thank you.
Thanks.